من عندكم من العراق يا سمر فلما يرويها
هذا هو العنوان العريض لحال العراق الذي
يعاني هذه الايام من اسوا سنه جفاف منذ
سنوات الامطار القليله وانحسار مياه اكبر
الانهار وهو دجله وسوى استخدام المياه
فضلا عن التغير المناخي وزياده الجفاف
كلها اسباب لهذه الازمه ومع الشح المائي
تاتي ازمات اخرى تتعلق بالمؤن والزراعه
حيث يزيد انحسار الاراضي الزراعيه مع ازمه
المياه كل ذلك يدفع العراقيين للقلق على
مستقبلهم المائي خصوصا وان الحلول تغيب
تماما المزيد دوما مع زينب المشاط من
العراق
[موسيقى]
في هذه البقعه تسري عروق العراق التاريخيه
قال الشاعر الجواهري في يوم من الايام يا
دجله الخير يا ام البساتين لكن المياه تشح
في بلد المياه والبساتين تنازع بسبب
الجفاف
[موسيقى]
الاربع الماضيه كانت الاسوا من حيث تصاعد
مؤشرات الجفاف في العراق شحال الامطار
والتغير المناخي سيطر على حال البلاد
المائي واكدت وزاره الموارد المائيه ان
هذا العام هو عمق زجاجه الازمه والاكثر
حرجا منذ ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي وهذا ما
يسبب تهديدا للامن المائي العراقي كل يوم
[موسيقى]
تتراجع المياه المخزونه في سدود العراق
فمن 60 مليار متر مكعب في عام 2016 يهبط
الرقم بشكل مخيف الى سبعه مليارات
وخمسمائه مليون متر مكعب وهذا الرقم ضئيل
جدا مقارنه بحاجه العراق من المياه
[موسيقى]
الازمه ليست مائيه فحسب فما يحدث من شح
المياه تنعكس اثاره على قوه العراقيين
اليومي وبالتالي تخرج الاف الهكتارات
الزراعيه عن الخطه الانتاجيه ويصبح العراق
تحت تهديد نقص حاد بالخيرات الزراعيه التي
كانت يوما ما عنوانا لبلاد وادي الرافدين
زينب المشاه صباح العربيه البصره
شكرا يا زينب على فكره تقرير رائع واضح
غير المناسب اصلا كنت في العراق قبل شهر
تقريبا بعد 20 سنه غياب وتفاجات انه فعلا
ما يدج كان جدا نازل يعني شبه بحيره موهر
هو من اكبر الانهار في العالم الفرات
للاسف يعني ما بعرف هلا خلينا نشوف يمكن
الخبير البيئي سينضم الينا بعد قليل عضو
الاتحاد الدولي للطبيعه ايمن القدوري اللي
يحدثنا عن هذه الظاهره صباح الخير سيد
ايمن يعني السؤال الاول قد يكون بديه
يسمعنا بتقرير الزميله زينب قبل قليل ان
التغير المناخي ولكن يعني ما هي الطرق
التي تعمل وزاره الزراعه العراقيه لتفادي
الجفاف او انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه اذا صح
التعبير
صباح الخير عليكم وشكرا على هذه الاستطاعه
الاستضافه واشكركم على تناولكم هذا الملف
لحاجتي في الوقت الحالي العراق الان يعيش
ازمه مائيه
شارفت على الوصول الى نقطه اللاعوده
خصوصا ان هذه المرحله حرجه جدا بسبب قله
الساقط المطري بالنسبه
للاسباب التي ادت الى الوصول للعراق وضع
المائي للعراقي لهذا الحد ليست متعلقه في
التغير الناقل فقط هناك اسباب داخليه
وخارجيه تتعلق بحصص العراق المائيه هي
كانت السبب الاكبر في خساره العراق لهذه
الثروه المائيه بالنسبه لخطط وزاره
الزراعه وزاره الموارد المائيه دائما ما
نعلق على هذا الموضوع هناك تضارب بين
الجهتين العراق يمتلك ما يقارب 48 مليون
دونم زراعي هذه ال 48 دونم زراعي عام
قلصت الى والان بالخطه الزراعيه الاخيره
قلص النصف الى النصف يعني نحن الان نعمل
بربع القيمه من هذه
الجوانب الزراعيه بسبب الشحن المائيه
الشحن المائيه مرتبطه بعوامل داخليه مثل
ما ذكرت العوامل الداخليه ابرزها هو
التجاوز على المجاري المائيه من قبل
مزارعين او جهات متنفثه
بانشائها بحيرات الاسماك الغير مرخصه فتح
قنوات غير مرخصه لاعراض الزراعيه معينه
دون اخرى وغير مدرجه ضمن الخطه الزراعيه
لوزاره الزراعه بالتالي هناك تشتت في
عمليه تطبيق القانون مع ادى الى
تلف المجاري المائي
رداءه نوعيه المياه في الوقت التي الذي
تكون فيه منسوباتها جدا قليله زين ايمن
احنا تكلمنا عن كل الاسباب اللي ادتها هل
هناك يعني حلول مطروحه على طاوله النقاش
هل هناك حديث مع الدول اللي الها يد في
هذا الجفاف اللي يحصل اليوم في العراق
يعني ما الحل
نعم هناك حلول لكن هذه الحلول ليست متوفره
بالمعنى الصريح للوفره يعني حل لكل مؤسسه
حكوميه
وحل لابد منه هو تدويل ملف المياه العراق
على على ما اعتقد انه اليوم بعد الظهر او
غدا سيتوجه العراق بوفد رسمي
برئاسه رئيس الوزراء محمد الشيعه السوداني
الى تركيا لبحث ملف المياه ثانيا هناك
مؤتمر سينعقد في نهايه شهر شهر اذار في
نيويورك معني بشان المائي وتوجه دعوه
رسميه للعراق للمشاركه على العراق ان
يستغل الوضع الحالي العراقي الان في اوج
عظمه قوته في
والامكانيات التي ممكن ان تتوفر له عن غير
عن اوقات سابقه لان يمتلك الان القوه
للمفاوضه على ملف المياه واس الحقوق
المائيه
بتسخير ملفات اخرى كالملف الاقتصادي
والملف السياسي الان الوقت
الافضل
لمفاوضه كل من تركيا وايران على حصه
العراق المائيه
وارجاع اطلاقات المائيه الى ما قبل عام
2014 2014 كان هناك مذكره تفاهم مع
الحكومه التركيه بان تطلق ما يقارب 500
متر مكعب في الثانيه وهذه ايضا ليست الحصه
الحقيقيه للعراق العراق يجب ان يستلم اكثر
من 750 متر مكعب في الثانيه الخبير البيئي
وعضو الاتحاد الدولي للطبيعه ايمن القدوري
شكرا على هذه المشاركه وان شاء الله يعني
تحل هذه الازمه في بلد نهرين